well that could have gone better look  we've all lost dearly our people our  homes the light is getting snuffed out  soulless the last star and this motley  crew is all that is left to save it  we get in this yet we fight each other  over the scraps while the lesion of  cosmic horrors and a traitorous scum  back consumed the universe got another  it's time to be the badasses we were  born to be live together or die alone oh  yes carpet  it's so cute how you think you can stop  thrown us will fall you just called down  the thunder and Dane we were born for  this  we're the battle for  all ready to rock yeah little something  right here big guy huh so did I get it  yeah you're good okay  you